es wird gerade ist es gerade nach
deswegen mit dunkel aaron times at 0 und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge wäre ein kraftwerk sollte am
freitag heute ist reiter gehe jedenfalls
wurden mir wieder cooles teig zuge
seiner per mail an kontrakte gmail.com
da könnt ihr mir auch kommentare hin
werden wenn ihr wollt und die habe ich
gedacht habe die ich bin heute auch
wieder eine dieser tag heute schon
wieder zehn jahre in der uni dann noch
dies gemacht und ich habe mir wieder 56
rausgesucht ich würde mich freuen wenn
ihr bis zum ende dran bleibt und dann
würde ich sagen jetzt erst effekt wurde
mir zugesendet von nikkei power dragon
lp und zwar seht ihr schon ich laufe
hier rum ich spiele im schwierigkeit
modus schwer oder normal auf jeden fall
alles außer friedlich und ihr seht schon
jetzt unten als ich hüpfe die ganze zeit
rum liegen die und jetzt verliere ich
jeden moment da derzeit eine hungerkur
da seht ihr schon jetzt habe ich eine
halbe hunger keule verloren jetzt habe
ich noch eine verlor jeden moment
tendiere ich wieder eine halbe und das
ganze ist jetzt zum beispiel passiert
und jetzt verliere ich jeden moment
wieder nadal wird zum beispiel und wenn
ihr euch jetzt denkt ich habe gar keinen
bock mehr darauf dass ich irgendwie die
ganze nummer köln von ihr könnt die ganz
einfach in den friedlich modus umstellen
und 150 euro hunger call nämlich einfach
auf und das ganze geht locker i7
friedlich modus da lebt man natürlich
auch so wiederum arbeiten aber als
natürlich nicht so schnell wie bei den
anderen und das fühlst du mir ruckelt
das ganze ein bisschen aber so ist auf
jeden fall mega sie hat man sich einfach
die hunger
kkw auffällt wenn man einem höheren
schwierigkeitsgrad ist und das perfekt
meinte jetzt compact mit mind die zweite
sache wurde mir zugesendet von mégane
wilhelm oder megan wilhelm oder
irgendwie so ich hoffe ich spreche dann
richtig aus und zwar meint er das oder
oder sie oder ich top mengen ist ein
frauenname oder luca wegen fox egal
jedenfalls als wir zugesendet das items
schneller beziehungsweise langsamer
fallen als spieler sich das ganze mal
selbst herausfinden soll jetzt hier
nämlich einfach mal ich habe so eine
kleine konstruktion gebaut ich weiß ich
bin ich der große respekt aber das habe
ich auch irgendwie hin gekriegt weil
sich hier den schalter so dann gehen die
beiden automatisch auf und so gehen sie
wieder zu das heißt sie schmeiße ich
jetzt einfach ebenso ein item drauf da
und jetzt mache ich einmal zack und
jetzt völlig automatisch runter
unterseite mit ihr seht schon zackig
minuten hieß der test und da kommt erst
das alte mal also ich bin viel viel
schneller das blöde session noch der
klebrige kolba das ist nicht schon test
gewesen aber ich bin viel viel schneller
item das kommt nicht darauf an ob das
jetzt ein eisen blog ist er weg vom
eisen blog genommen und nicht irgendwie
ich weiß nicht was gibts ja vielleicht
alte wie holz ist auf jeden fall
leichter als in einem blumenfeld immer
viel viel schneller runter als items das
liegt nicht daran also ich meine ich
selber sondern komplette eisenbahn weil
man sich das mal überlegt extrem viel
und davide endlich mehr als dieser
kleines tief oder konkreter charakter
mehr oder weniger micro aber jedenfalls
fällt man immer viel viel schneller als
die alters- und das perfekt
ein effekt sinnvoll packe ich wusste
alles
dritte wurde mir zugesendet von dustin
und zwar man das denn dass es einen
unterschied macht ob ich einen pfeil
gegen die obere hälfte einer türkis oder
gegen die untere hälfte einer türe nicht
die tür dann nämlich auf machen und spaß
mache ich das jetzt einfach mal die
schießerei auf die untere hälfte der tür
ihr seht schon der fall bleibt er stecke
ich mach die tür auf und der fliegt nach
unten wenn ich jetzt allerdings die tür
mal so nehme und ich schieße einen fall
da oben gegen machte jetzt die tür auf
seht ihr der pfeil bleibt quasi in der
luft stecken jetzt kommen wahrscheinlich
gedacht die tür ist ein entity oder
engelhardt wird er oft kritisiert ich
weiß nicht woran es liegt es ist
allerdings so ist es ein fake engagiert
und nein hin oben hin ich mache die tür
auf der obere bleibt auf der stelle der
untere feld runter aber noch erarbeitet
erstmal gelöst und das war fact nummer
drei meine lieben freund ich weiß nicht
warum ich das überhaupt sagen dass das
der und effekt war weil ihr das
eigentlich selber kombinieren können und
ich extra diese anzeigefläche deswegen
schon eingebaut habe wie die
fantastischen vier oder mehr effekt
nummer 4 wurde mir zugesendet von xbox
zocker und zwar mit xbox zocker in ein
ganz normales inventar passen genau 2324
schauen ich finde das immer blöd wenn
man einen sumpf soll das ganze dann hier
total
es wird gerade ist es grad nachts
deswegen wird es dunkel
im set 0 jedenfalls kam jetzt einfach
mal in unser inventar reinschauen und
dann sieht man hier 1 2 3 4 und 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9
wenn man viermal neuen rechnen kommt was
kommt denn bei 49 rost 36 jahre genau
das 136 luca erste klasse ist bei dir
auch hängen geblieben und in jede slot
passen 64 items das heißt man kann 64 x
36 rechnung das sind 2304 das hab ich
auch nicht im kopf gerechnet eine fake
sci-fi die retina und straff in letzter
zeit ich weiß dass jetzt leute ankommen
ach guck mal hier kann zuordne gold
rüstung reinpacken oder sowas und hier
kann es auch noch jeweils 64
dann kommt hier auch wieder wenn ich ihr
64 holz hier richtig krieg durch die
crafting tempo aber ich mache jetzt
einfach nur diese taschen hier die ich
in der hand nehmen kann inventar passen
genau 2000 2003 100
das ist schon extrem viel und
das perfekte nummer vier ein bisschen
mathematik kann ja nicht schaden okay
eigentlich kein mathematik schon schaden
also ich hasse der fünfte fact wurde mir
zugeredet von constantin eckner econ sie
und ihr seht einfach da oben immer noch
die plattform wo ich den zweiten fact
vorgestellter jedenfalls wollte ich das
ganze mit euch zusammen aufbauen damit
ihr seht dass da nicht irgendwie falsch
angepackt habe und zwar hab ich jetzt
einfach mal ein wolle fällt was sich
hier hinsetzt und platziere ich nun
fackeln drauf ihr seht hier sind so ein
paar fackeln alt war am start wenn ich
ganz normal ein lieber wolle darüber
laufe ist es ja eigentlich so hört man
immer so einen ganz kleinen wolle
wenn ich allerdings hier jetzt drüber
köpfte ihr seht hier sind alles fackeln
aber darunter ist auch wolle und höre
ich einen einen holzzaun das wirklich
über holz fünfmal ich zeig euch das
jetzt einfach mal okay ich hoffe dass
konnte man jetzt irgendwie verstehen ich
wäre das wahrscheinlich nachteil in der
nachbearbeitung bisschen von oli
verstärkung plus zehn dezibel gemacht
haben oder irgendwie so nah plus zehn
millionen bilder mit der an krebs leidet
an krebs habe ich nicht eigentlich
trommelfell gehört zusammen
ich bin kein mikrofon das jetzt weil
feld nummer fünf wenn man irgendwie hier
auch ganz normal wolle habt ihr könnt
ihr auch steine hin packen das mit sich
trotzdem so an als wäre das holz weil
man einfach über diese fackel mehr oder
weniger drüber springen ja das hängt
immer fünf und damit würde ich sagen war
es das auch schon wieder für die heutige
episode der effekt erzeugt gefallen
natürlich selber eine bewertungs freuen
und schreibt mir doch bitte cool effect
per mail an kontrakte gmail.com oder
bitte einfach in die kommentare weil
meine facetime schilder und wurde über
die kommentare kann man das auch mal
ganz gut raus fällt dann auch sachen gut
sind oder schlecht sind weil sie damit
daumen hoch beziehungsweise daumen
runter bewertet wurde und dann will ich
sagen sehen wir uns in der nächsten
folge am dienstag wieder ciao